she is brain listeners Jesus brain is
brought to you and sponsored by better
help with me David so listen when you
spend all of your time giving sometimes
you can feel a little stretched thin and
burned out well guess what therapy can
give you the tools to find a more better
and more better it's just a better
balance in your life so you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind and listen I've
benefited from a therapy my whole life
I've been taking therapy I've talked
about it openly for a very long time now
so you know why not give it a try better
help can be that thing for you if you're
thinking of starting therapy do it with
Better Health just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get bashed with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
any time for no additional charge find
more bowels with better help visit
betterhelp.com change today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
help.com genius along here I snapped all
these rules and why is that a catalyst
for the world ending he doesn't belong
he's an anomaly maybe he could do what
he wants and create his Destiny because
you're right he's not supposed to be
Spider-Man right so maybe in this
reality which is a reality that's not
supposed to exist he's Spider-Man anyway
yeah why not have his in five four three
two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast I
did a podcast all by myself but now I'm
here with my recurring co-host Ed Park a
P we are going to get straight into this
I know sometimes we kind of get
distracted
but
um probably one of the best Marvel films
I've seen in my [__] life yeah it was
Spider-Man into the the cross across the
spider first across the spider verse
right
um number one even before this film came
out I already had high expectations for
it because the first one was so [__]
amazing yes
um I didn't realize how good this film
was going to be
um there are so many things that we
could break down individually we can go
through the film
um
and I there's so many thoughts that I
have I actually don't know how to
organize it right that's all right I
think it would be okay to just throw it
all out there and just as just piece it
all together as we go okay I mean I'm
just going to talk about a few things
right so if you guys haven't watched
this film spoiler alert
um you should [__] watch so go watch
it first and then then listen to this
podcast after one of the things that I
think that this this they actually
changed a lot yeah and they improved a
lot in places that I didn't think needed
Improvement which threw me off
what it for for one thing like right
when I noticed off the Jump is um what's
it called um how detailed they were in
the scenes in terms of how emotive like
when the emotions came out how they
changed the background in the scenes for
what was happening so you could focus on
the characters that [__] off jump I was
like genius that's so [__] genius
yeah it was so good when when it started
off in the beginning and she was talking
to her father right and they're in the
bedroom you you kind of see all these
bright colors but the bright colors in
the back are all muted all the furniture
is muted the way that it's drawn how is
detailed it's all muted in the people
that are focused on it's just the two
characters right
her father is this warm like orange
glowing color and everywhere she goes
and walks she's this blue She's Got the
Blues like it's so Express it's art man
it's [__] art yeah like when I was
looking at this and I I think I the
reason why I wanted to watch this two
times was because I kept processing
everything that I was watching in real
time yeah so there are definitely
moments that I missed in the film right
because I just kept thinking
when I first saw that I was like this is
something that actual film would not be
able to replicate yeah this is the
closest that we're going to get to
watching a comic book come to life yes
yes that's the aesthetic that's why like
you're looking at it like it's flat
right but it's got It's got a depth to
it but it's flat
because they were they from the first
film too you could see like they wanted
to make it look like you're looking at
comic book pages which is why when you
saw people moving in fast motion
the motion blur was the the CMYK print
splitting yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
when you see a comic book and the color
gets misprint like yeah like oh [__]
it's so smart and then when it when it's
showing shading it's showing rap the
rasterization dots right like oh my God
this aesthetic right and then you come
to this film
and when the way they build their worlds
it's like every Universe has its own
aesthetic yes
and that's where they ramp that up and
they so they actually made the universes
have their own characteristics in them
yeah
it's such so [__] great and I thought
to myself when I was watching this like
I didn't think that there was going to
be a film
I don't know how people might feel about
this especially because I should be
you know
my Asian American side wants to say
everything everywhere all at once was
the best Multiverse film ever and the
thing comes sliding in yes I was like yo
but I was gonna say the same thing bro I
was gonna say the same thing the the
night I saw it Friday night
over at midnight I didn't sleep till
like 6 45 A.M
and I have wrote down my thoughts in the
beginning of my paragraph is
this reminds me of everything everywhere
all at once yeah and I started from
there and I can expound on that like we
have all the time in the world to
expound on that but for me it's like for
this is a generational the defining film
which is a great way to start the early
years of the 2020s right like we had
parasite
and we had everything everywhere all at
once
and then I'm not saying these because
I'm trying to say Asian movies no but
because of how they're defining this
decade how is defining a generation I
was defining our culture today not just
because it's Asian [__] because I'm
talking about this movie too is such a
generation defining like movie about
like how we are responding to what we
were taught by the Boomers and the
establishment and how things are
supposed to be yeah and the [__]
story we want to write for ourselves
which is the major theme of this movie
and the reason why you're feeling that
way with everything everywhere is
because these are both
classified as meta modern movies they
are meta narratives because
you know the original like Boomer movies
like from the beginning of its
conception like you know Thomas Edison
invented the film camera
oh for reals yeah the the film industry
was in New Jersey dude like it was in
the east coast like New York and [__]
but you know what because he had all
this
proprietary use of all these cameras and
[__] he made these rules like
like about what he thought was moral and
all this [__] so your movies have to do
this just like just propaganda right
but and then like so that's like how
films started and before it moved to
Hollywood to leave those [__] Edison
rules you know and but then the story
they were telling in the way films were
originally used is still propaganda like
hey this is the world we live in this is
what we do this is what we think of bad
guys is what we do to bad guys right
this is how to follow the rules this is
how to grow up and Obey you know all
these things right then we get
post-modern you might classify it like
it started with late Boomers with like
I'm gonna say like the 70s films because
of Richard Nixon's
um whole Watergate scandal just open the
minds of Americans like you can't trust
the government you know like they're
lying to us they're doing all the secret
[__] what all this stuff I mean the the
assassination of JFK it built this
cynicism into America in the 70s and
it's reflected in those movies of a taxi
driver and the Godfather the bad guys
movies about bad guys winning yeah yeah
you know then you get to Gen X
post-modern movies then you got people
like Quentin Tarantino fumbling all of
these scenes totally non-linear movie
yet it's just like a coherent story so
not only are they [__] with the
narrative but they're [__] with the
format of telling a story you got
someone like Christopher Nolan telling a
whole entire movie [__] backwards and
it makes sense when you see it yeah yeah
you see the beginning of the movie at
the end
they're just they're expressing and
changing the way film is is sad right
but look at us Millennials and how we
like what what are we gonna create and
such right what do we do
the Boomers and Gen X they created
everything they created all the
franchises they created all the IP you
know and everything like the work that
comes to the people who make it up to
the top what's their job take care of
this IP right
and so like
the
I feel like the
Our Generations and this decades and gen
Z included coming into this decade and
expressing ourselves
is us being told
what to do by the establishment
but what we're going to do you know with
our own story we know that that's what
you're telling us to do but we have our
own story to tell and that is the
general that's the theme of like
everything everywhere as well
like
you've taken the establishment and and
established storytelling model
and then you flip it on his head with
throwing everything that was ever
presented to you
then you bring in the cynicism of the
post-modernism because that's a lot of
what post-modern films were that just
kind of brought cynicism and you know
just kind of a Dark Age
but then the metal modern narrative is
like how we are going to take the
positive outcome while acknowledging
all of the negative as well yeah yeah so
on everything everywhere at the end of
it the cynicism they accept like sure
nothing matters because we could be
anywhere and everywhere but I want to be
right here with you at this dirty
laundromat yeah
to love you here because nothing matters
anyway right
and so it's a way of acceptance of this
messed up world and the rules that we're
living under while acknowledging you
know asking the Boomers and the
establishment to acknowledge
yeah the plight you know but us also
having to manage our expectations
because the first you know into the
spider-verse film what did he graffiti
on the wall
no expectations yeah yeah yeah the
message that he's trying to cross like
mile morale's character is a kid with no
expectations for his future yeah you
know and so like when it goes off man
like at the starting on the film where
she's playing drums and then so it's
expressing her feelings and like you're
seeing this beautiful watercolor but
then you're seeing how she feels just
through the art
and then what's going on like her father
is the captain right and so she tells
her story
um basically Peter Parker turns into a
lizard yeah and he ends up dying and her
father thinks that she the one who
killed him killed Peter Parker so he's
been after her
and
they end up this is also this is
meta-narrative they're at the Guggenheim
Museum right
and then and so there's this vulture
from a da Vinci universe
right and she calls them the Renaissance
like man right and he sees this 2023 art
at the Guggenheim and they start having
an argument about what is art yeah yeah
yeah and it's like of course they're
talking about this film right and I
think in the bigger picture the the
biggest question even in the first uh
into the spider-verse was you know what
is Spider-Man who is Spider-Man what
makes you Spider-Man right and they
proved it's not just Peter Parker
because everybody in that film is not a
Peter Parker except Peter B Parker the
depressed divorcement yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah right
and
man
this this film is so layered too so they
have this you know argument about art
and that fact that we're talking about
it makes it art
and then uh the Spider Woman Issa Ray
comes through
and
what'd you think about our character
from her side because she's cool as [__]
as she comes in I mean she kind of
reminded me of of honestly like a cool
motherly figure right that she didn't
have because she has her father figure
there and like she doesn't have a woman
influence and that's her woman influence
automatically will you adopt me exactly
exactly and so you know you know when
you look at like the household
upbringing right you know we always talk
about that the the Dual house where you
have a mother and a father right and
somebody's always looking for a figure
to look up to and so when she saw her
and you know in the previous film and
obviously in the film and the way it
starts you have a young girl who's
blossoming into a woman right and this
is what I really like too I feel I
really feel like this film just off the
Jump
allowed us as adults to kind of see
ourselves as teenagers and we're also
kind of in this age where our friends
are also parents yes and so you see this
weird dynamic that they have that's
weird but also very [__] familiar
like we've been through her stage like I
want to tell you everything but I'm
scared to I'm afraid what you're going
to say I know what I'm doing I have my
own path I want to still make you proud
right but that girl also needs a
motherly figure and so when she came in
I'm like that's her mom figure yeah
right everything that she wants to see
in a cool [__] mom
she comes in and then Miguel O'Hara's
Spider-Man 2099 comes in [__] badass
[__] right [__] He's Got Claws he's
got like this sketch characteristic on
him he's [__] cool as [__] off his
[__] buff as [__] um he's got like also
semi vampire uh powers or something yeah
so uh are you familiar with this
backstory no not at all I wasn't either
so I had to look it up so
he is from Another Universe this guy uh
Miguel O'Hara he works for alchemix
and
I guess he wanted to quit his job
because he found out the company was
shady
and then as at the fair wear well party
his boss roofies him
with this drug this future drug
that automatically gets him hooked and
addicted to it and because of that drug
he loses his wife and kid and his and
his family and so it but it's boss did
that to him to make him continue working
for his company
and so
uh in that he while working for the
company he found this serum to help with
his drug addiction which is the thing he
punched in his arm it's like the spider
venom and it makes his DNA 50 spider I
guess
and so that's what he did he came up
with the suit and all the technology and
[__] so that's his backstory as a
character and then she's dark as [__]
yeah so yeah he's from the 90s so the
Scarlet Spider is in this one too right
the the one with the hoodie the blue
hoodie classic 90 Spider-Man but that at
that time they were trying to bring like
darker Spider-Man you know mellow
Melancholy kind of characters but yeah
um
they get into a fight they practically
destroy the place
um
what's her name Gwen comes to the action
from a helicopter falling down and she
[__] webs up the joints super dope
sequence
but in that mess I mean she saves her
father's life
uh he catches her and he points a gun
and says stop right there because he
still believes that she killed Peter
Parker
and so she does the thing that she's
most scared to do
she reveals herself to her father saying
look why would I like why would I kill
Peter what does her father do
you earned a rest yeah you have the
right to remain silent Miranda rights
yeah
and
in that moment the the other spider
people a Spider Woman and the Miguel
O'Hara
come in they trap up her dead and they
take her with her so they she
Spider-Woman ends up taking Gwen under
her wing
and so that's when title card comes up
and then we're back with
um miles
uh where does Mouse come in they kind of
recap his story from the last movie
right yeah they basically talk about you
know where his life has been in the last
year or so or however long it's been he
grew a little bit right he's 15. he's
enjoying the fame taking selfies uh has
done brand deal endorsements you know
living living his life you know as a
superhero star Spiderman of New York
right yeah well he's in Brooklyn though
and so right he's introduced along with
this new character named spot
is uh trying to steal an ATM because he
says he lost his job you know
and
his powers is basically like have you
played that game portal
no well it's it's like you I mean you
get the cops yeah yeah right I mean
um he basically creates these portals
through his these ink plots on his body
and that's where uh you know miles comes
in to save this so they fight but in the
meantime he's late to this meeting with
his parents and the guidance counselor
right
and so
as for fighting he does not respect this
guy's spot at all
and he calls him the villain of the week
and he gets him locked up out webbed up
and then he gets into the meeting super
late
and this is a very interesting like
conversation that happens now it's
because I watched it three times because
I I was obsessed with this like I knew I
had to pay attention here because she
brings up a blank piece of paper and
says like this is every kid's Universe
right it's like your son has to fit into
here obviously a metaphor for putting
kids in a box and such things and she's
like I have no idea who your son is
right
um and you got to pay attention to the
meta Narrative of what they're saying
and who's saying this and who would say
this out here in our real life
he comes in and then
she says Ah here's your story right
the young black latino immigrant what
you know was with a struggling family in
Brooklyn right
and then their parents object too
yeah I'm from Puerto Rico Puerto Rico's
America yeah and I'm not an immigrant
and then his dad's like I own a floor in
Brooklyn I don't think I'm struggling
right so I mean that's disrespectful
right but then it's like this
old white lady like this is the story
that people want to hear this is what
people want to see this is what colleges
want to see right
and so she's trying to put him in a box
right and but even the parents can see
that's not what they want to do right
but is that's the game then yeah miles
you gotta you know come along but he's
like
you're seeing like what he wants to do
is go to Princeton mom wants to go to go
to college in Brooklyn
right and so he's expressing how much he
wants to travel and get out there right
while still another Parental Guidance
figure is holding him back
you know in Brooklyn
and while he's expressing that he's got
to get out there but once again the
dude's spot gets out
they end up in that same Multiverse
machine thing
from the first movie and then he
explains like ah this is where it all
happened yeah you created me and I
created you
his backstory is that
in their research with the the machine
they brought a spider
From Another Universe to study but for
those spider bites but that got let go
and that's the spider that end up biting
miles
and so I was looking at
into the spider-verse if you'd notice
there was all these hints about 42 right
yeah it was never explained yeah and now
it's explained in this movie
yeah it's from a universe Earth 42.
and
so
in that case that created miles as
Spider-Man
but full circle he came back to destroy
the machine and then destroying the
machine it affected him like is it
science experiment gone wrong and now
he's got all these holes in him and
that's what he's become so it's like you
created me too
and Miles doesn't respect it yeah you
don't care
right I don't know what the [__] you're
talking about like I still don't know
who you are which is like infuri into
it's very dismissive yeah and he's like
you threw a bagel at me yeah which was
like one of the you know small little
Mimi jokes that came out of the first
film and it's great that they brought it
back
but it's like he's like hey man I've
thrown various Foods at bunch of people
you just don't care right and because of
that he feels he starts getting [__]
angry he's like I'm gonna make you
recognize me and understand how linked
we are but he's still a bumbling fool
and he kicks himself in the ass and
falls into himself in his own holes
right
and then
so what ends up is Spider-Man has a
conversation with
Jeff Morales miles is dead
right and it's
it shows how miles can finally say the
things he wants to say as his dad with a
person with the mask on
and then but at the same time as he's
saying these things he's gaining the
empathy and Viewpoint of his father
right
and
yeah in that moment like even the way
like
you know New York is New York it's a
Concrete Jungle but then when they
started using that tarp oh yeah they
look like waves of an ocean you're like
and he's got his arm spread out like
this you're like damn man how is this
movie like just they can make it [__]
beautiful man yeah they're visually just
so expressively good man yeah now what
happens next so after they had that
conversation right I I think that might
be jumping to this part too but then
miles is Dad's birthday
that's right
spot
it's his uh it's him becoming captain
the spot dude is inside his himself like
his own little universe and he finds out
that he can go into either go into other
universes and like so he comes into a
universe and it looks like a Art Deco
old ass you know Archie comic right
and then he gets on and he goes into
this little Lego Universe
right
do you hear about this on Twitter
a 14 year old black Canadian kid
animated that entire series I heard he
did that whole thing after school yeah
crazy crazy insane have you seen his
other work no so it looks like a major
Studio who makes Lego movies did it
like so
they released across the spider verse uh
teaser right years ago
and then he recreated it with Legos
right the directors uh Phil Lord
Christopher Miller are the writers
producers
they saw on Twitter the next day they
were like hey do you want to animate an
entire sequence
because they were still in the middle of
finishing it and they added that
sequence in from 14 year old kid dude
that's dog people kids are so talented
man and the technology that's accessible
to them that allows them to do this [__]
too oh my God and you know what's
amazing about that I can't wrap my head
around it I I barely still know how to
use [__] After Effects it's so hard
for me to wrap my head around in my head
I was thinking like did they get the the
guys who made The Lego Movie to do this
because uh Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller they made the Lego movie they
made the first one oh that's right yeah
yeah you guys don't miss like we'll talk
about their the history of their films
but yeah like that's what I thought at
first and then I learned a 14 year old
kid did it like damn I actually really
appreciate that from them too because
it's so easy for somebody in their
position just to be like oh we want to
add a Lego thing here we could just do
it ourselves and steal his idea and then
nobody would know for otherwise even the
kid probably wouldn't know yeah but
instead they're like hey let's give this
kid a chance that's larda Miller man
they're [__] excellent and with the
kids films but they also make really
great you know regular adult films I
mean not like porn but like rated R
films but yeah so
um he finds out that his holes are an
access to different universes and in the
Multiverse and so what he's got to do is
now just get more machine parts to build
a little collider again you know for
himself and just do it multiple times
over and over and over right
and that's then we see Miles trying to
get a cake at a cake shop
and this is important too like because
he's saying so much the the Cake Maker
has to write too much on there she says
you know why don't you say something
shorter right but he comes up with a
different solution he gets two cakes
right and what do the guidance
counselors say before you can't have
your cake and eat it too yeah and he's
like then I'll have more cake like the
idea of him coming up with his own
solution is is like a theme in this film
and
uh he ends up getting to the meeting
late so uh in their argument
you're seeing that his parents are
pissed off at him because he's always
missing and the kindness counselor was
saying he's lying to you lying to you
about some and then it's clear they want
to know what's up why are you missing
class you know why are you you're your
head in the air all that [__] and he
wants to say that he's Spider-Man and
then when he gets the chance of the
Music Stops like I can't say it you know
um that argument ends up with him
getting grounded getting sent to his
room and then all of a sudden
Gwen Stacy comes out through a portal
and then she explains about this secret
covert Ops group of spider people and
different multiverses get this wrist
thing and so you know she wanted to come
by and say hello but then what we really
see is that she's on a mission like
she's surveilling spot
but what we also see is that she's
neglecting her responsibilities to go
hang out with Miles yeah and they have
this [__] beautiful scene on top of
that Dome Tower oh my God that was so
[__] dope man I need to get a
panorama poster of that [__] you know
like with I I really liked that that
cake scene specifically because it's so
just it's very
it's a precise portrayal of what it's
like to be a misunderstood team right
because from their parents eyes they see
this kid that's not trying hard enough
because they understand their kids
potential they see how smart he is he's
basically on a route to going to an Ivy
League College though so they see his
intelligence right yeah and so they the
only perspective that they see is they
see this young kid that's [__] up
that's not living up to his potential
they're trying to tell him to stop
[__] this up but on the other side
this kid is trying his best he's
literally trying his best but the hard
part about this is a lot of us find out
as we get older it's like you really
can't do have your cake and eat it too
you're trying to balance two different
lives yeah right and how do you do this
there's no honesty in this at all which
when they bring up that whole thing your
kid's lying to you like to me it was a
representation of like how far how long
can you live a dishonest life how long
can you be a dishonest person and try to
balance it out right right and it just
reminded me of being a kid it's like
you're not trying hard enough as a kid
your friend frustrated like I am trying
you just don't [__] know because it's
not in the way that you see fit so like
that was such a good representation of
what it's like to be a misunderstood
teenager yeah I mean like because I'm
loving the way it's portrayed here in
this movie because when I say teens and
gen Z and other movies call me an ageist
man I'm like this [__] [__] yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like Ant-Man and the
lost Quantum mania this [__] [__]
yeah but this film was just like
like you yeah like there's [__] great
empathy points because they're just not
making a movie for Gen Z to cater to
them they're it's a real character it's
a real 15 year old in this day and age
and just just as a perspective to what I
really enjoy about this film is that
they're building character through
action only yeah there hasn't been this
moment in this film already and we've
already talked about a lot of we only
talked about like maybe 25 of this film
at this point right we haven't gone that
far yeah where they're building
character without him having to sit down
at a at the edge of a building and then
have a dialogue to him [__] to his
[__] self about how he feels about
what it's like if you don't know what
it's like to be a teenager dad you don't
need any of that stuff yeah if you've
been a teenager if you are a teenager
you look at that and you understand just
by seeing the social dynamic between a
parent and a child that's all that you
need and I really really appreciated
that because I understood everything
without it having to be said right I
mean like like in his conversation as
Spider-Man to his father his his father
is like I feel like my son is just lying
to me and keeping things from me right
yeah why would he do that it's like
because his dad is so intimidating right
um which is like uh one important story
point in uh God of War Ragnarok right
like you know Kratos in his character
he's a [__] [__] killer
right and he's a monster badass or
whatever right
and then you have this kid in this game
who is like keeping like telling lies
and keeping things from his father but
it's like the game is also portraying
like yeah to a kid to an intimidating
father like that why isn't it obvious
that they would keep things from you
yeah [__] scary as [__] and then
what's the consequence when they find
out you're lying even scarier rather
right I actually just keep up any any
reference to God of War that specific
one I'm gonna know because I watched all
the cut scenes yeah all the way through
so I'm watching all my five out five
hour drive back with my brother to
Sacramento yeah it's such a [__]
Solace all the story too right yeah
and so
um
miles and
Gwen on that rooftop like or the the
Dome like this beautiful thing because
gravity is just not there yeah they're
upside down and
you know he's telling her how he wants
to tell his parents that he's Spider-Man
then maybe they'll believe because
remember he even has that little fantasy
where he tells his parents he's Batman
and they're like oh don't worry about
you lying to us we love you anyway right
because that's how a kid would perceive
humor in this film by the way on point
so many [__] funny moments Lord and
Miller man Lord Miller
but
Gwen says don't do it my lovely Genius
of farts this podcast is brought to you
by better help that's right genius
playing with David so is sponsored by
betterhelp and my friends uh I've been
with better help for quite a while now
and they have been a consistent sponsor
because I have personally used better
help in my life uh it's super easy it's
super convenient and if you haven't
focused on your mental health this year
why not give it a go you have nothing to
lose it's so easy to get confident what
everyone else needs from you and you
just never take a moment to think about
what you need from yourself and that's
where better help can come in if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule so all you
really have to do is fill out a brief
questionnaire and you'll get matched
with the licensed therapist and by the
way you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com G's today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash genius
she just did it's only going to get
worse
right and she just advises like
you know just keep it to yourself
and they have that conversation about
their Destiny and who they're supposed
to be as Spider people
and then she says and every other
Universe Gwen Stacy Falls for Spider-Man
and he tries to get in close
and he says and she also says just like
what happened with father in every other
Universe terrible things happen because
of it
right
so it pulls back
which is like a thing that we understand
about Spider-Man about Gwen Stacy's
story right
you know it was a thing with Nerds when
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 trailer came
out
like
to all the super nerds they already knew
the ending
just by watching the trailer yeah yeah
because there's a shot of her like oh
right but it's the clothes she's wearing
she's wearing the exact same clothes she
wears when she dies in the comic book
and so all the super nerds were like oh
my God Gwen Stacey's dead Gwen say he's
gonna die yeah yeah and then all the
fans like there's no way they'll kill
Emma Stone right that's crazy their
chemistry is way too good right and what
happens like that is why because people
who understand Spider-Man and know the
story like new that's Canon that's
what's gonna happen right
and so what these two young spider
people
are looking at their established
storylines
and they're like what can we do
right can't we just do our own thing
and then do they think it interrupt why
the hell how does that scene even end
where things go oh that's right and and
then we find out she wasn't paying
attention so [__] accomplished
his whole goal like now he's shooting
all over the Multiverse and so Gwen gets
in trouble from Spider Woman
you know what her name was I just keep
calling her Spider Woman but Pam I'm
forgetting her I only saw it once Issa
Ray's character
and
you see you start seeing her colors
right as a mentor right she's like I
told you like I'm here for you yeah take
you under my wing I'll teach you the
ropes but if you mess this up that's on
you
I'm not here for you she makes it clear
like if you mess up that's not on me
and so she's stressed out she's [__]
up right and so she's got to chase this
spot dude
and
before that actually her parents I mean
uh Miles parents interrupt their little
oh that's right that's right that's
right that's right
and then because she quote unquote ices
his game
um
in their reconciliation but she tells
them to go like go after her
she's like
I can't be here and our we as your
parents we see you as our little boy and
it's hard to undo that but if you're
gonna go out there in the world she's
talking about college yeah but it's a
foreshadowing of this future of this
film she's like you have to take care of
yourself that little boy inside of you
you have to look after yourself and you
have to help yourself like get along
with people but if those people say you
don't belong don't let them feel make
you feel that way right then you go out
and you do your own thing
right
and then he goes and he [__] follows
her to Mumbai Hatton
and we go into another universe and it
is Spider-Man India
right
and
when we're introduced to this
um new universe
uh I forget what the Spider-Man is
called but he's an Indian Spider-Man
and
he is like man being Spider-Man is so
easy yeah
and it's kind of like oh like this is
before the bad stuff happens right it's
like oh I don't have to work out because
it makes me too big I help out with like
kids and then I have tea with my aunt
and all this stuff he's like perfect
Spider-Man I you know what I also looked
at as too that kind of cracked me up I'm
not sure if this was the purpose of it
in the writing but it's like
I thought it was like an Ode to just how
like Asian kids like what they normally
have to deal with this is [__]
nothing
you know what I mean like that's what it
felt like to me right like the the
typical stuff that Indian kids Indian
kids Asian Americans Asian kids are are
faced with on on The Daily like this is
a blessing man like I look at all this
stuff as a blessing you don't know what
I have what I have to go through without
these Powers Yeah I wouldn't be able to
juggle any of this type of [__] I have
so many things that are expected out of
me this [__] cake
well I thought though was that this was
the point before the Spider-Man goes
through all of this [__] oh 100 right
but
um
see they
they chase after a spot because he goes
to alchemex in that universe
and um
when he's trying to he builds a spot
builds up this force field and so
miles starts doing his electricity power
but then they're like sitting waiting on
what the [__] taking you so long
and then spider punk shows up and his
design is so dope because he looks like
he was cut out of a magazine yeah that's
what I was saying like
he's so flat but he has depth
it's like they cut him out of another
comic book and put him in there like
piece by piece and the other thing I
want to say is how they express frame
rates in here
because when they're just doing normal
life things it's classic
um save money type of
um animation where it's 12 frames a
second but whenever they do Spider-Man
[__] it turns to 24 frames per second
right
but this guy uh Hobbs Hobbies
uh Spider Punk
because he looks like a magazine cutout
he's going at like six frames yeah yeah
yeah right so he looks like stop-motion
animation
so yeah like just the style of it is so
dope so he comes in and
um
he's super anti-establishment as well I
think
um they failed to uh get spot and he
creates this big hole that drops the
entire building onto the city which
I mean there's this amazing rescue
sequence with the
the four of these spider people right
but damn if a million people didn't die
I don't know but yeah yeah it looks like
but in that we start seeing Spider-Man
India's
little Canon event starting to happen
right because
um he's
like has a in love with this girl whose
father is the captain of this of the
police in the city
and he's trying to save a little girl
and the building's gonna fall on top of
him but he's trying to save the girl and
he's also saying I can do both
whether he had to choose between the
girl or saving the captain he's like I
can do both
right
which is also kind of a thing that
happened in Spider-Man 1 with Toby
Maguire remember yeah Green Goblin had
the cable car with Mary Jane and a bunch
of New Yorkers and he did both
but in this Spider-Man he couldn't do
both
he opted to hang on to
um the girl of that universe and he's
trying to save the captain but what
happens is Miles goes in now Gwen grabs
his arm and tells him not to do it and
he's like no we gotta save these people
he goes down and he and ends up saving
the captain
and Gwen's
uh little wristwatch thing goes off and
it says Canon event disrupted
and this now she gets another
notification from the spider Squad they
show up straight up like you failed yeah
like you were supposed to make this
happen it didn't and so now there's this
huge hole middle of the city that's
swallowing up and that they have to try
to stop
and so now the rest of these spider
people have to answer to Miguel O'Hara
their boss so they end up
going into the spider-verse the
headquarters at dueva York yeah 2099.
and so for those of you out there too
who don't know what a Canon event is and
I'm pretty sure you've watched this but
if you haven't a Canon event is
basically the Catalyst that kind of puts
that onsets you know the character who
Spider-Man is right it's Canon right
story Canon yeah story Cannon so it's
like Superman will always come from
another planet in any iteration he'll
always be raised by some folks in Kansas
he'll always like these specific things
every time he's Rebooted
and so Spider-Man has all of these
specific events now that was the theme
of the first movie right the first film
was a love letter to origin stories
right and every time they told a
character came in their comic book
slapped on the page and he said I'm this
and I did this and this person died and
I went through this and now I'm this
right and they have this Montage every
single time and Miles doesn't get that
right only right up until the end when
his uncle Aaron dies yeah he goes
through his own little Canon event right
and so that's what we all understood
there we're trying to say hey this is
what Spider-Man is that's what they were
trying to tell us
now when we go into meeting Miguel
O'Hara and he starts explaining what the
Canon event is that's when we get all of
the the cameos and such and I gotta say
every theater I went to
they didn't freak out I had a very
respectful theater every single time
like all those crazy cameos you know why
I felt like that happened especially in
the theater I wasn't it too they were
they couldn't process everything right
that could be it it was so much [__]
they pretty much promises everything
yeah they didn't know what the [__] was
going on especially if like if you're
not a hardcore Marvel fan like the
terminology you're gonna get lost in
like seeing all these like Multiverse
stuff is really hard to handle right
unless you kind of read about it or you
kind of have a general idea of what uh
the Multiverse is in these Marvel films
yeah you know so I feel like a lot of
the times they were just kind of getting
lost and trying to understand what the
[__] is going on right you know and but
that's the thing like with how
you know like past few years I've been
also in that YouTube rabbit hole of
trying to understand Multiverse Theory
and how plausible it is and it's I gotta
say all of these Multiverse films do get
it right you know many times like with
how they try to explain it like the
possibilities of it theoretically
you know and so it it just that's what I
mean about like if we're talking about
this now imagine the movies 10 years
from now Beyond talking telling more
Multiverse crazy man yeah
so
um they explain
um what a Canon event is like how
every iteration of Spider-Man goes
through these specific strategies that
we all understand right and it's like
for him it was his uncle Aaron right
and then we saw the Cameo with like the
live-action Spider-Man we saw the video
game Spider-man we see [__] Donald
Glover as a Prowler again and like so
yeah all these great cameos but then the
point of it being that we all experience
this and that's what makes us us right
and then he was at reiterating but
there's the other thing that also
happens is that the captain of the
police that is a very close
um relation
to the Spider-Man will
will die and it will greatly affect the
way that Spider-Man of the universe you
know is affected you know or it goes
about his life that's something that has
to happen and you you weren't even
supposed to be in that universe and you
prevented that Canon event from
happening so that's why this what was
happening and then he's like
mahil says how do you know
it's like you [__] up
yeah but then which is a viable question
though because when he says how do you
know because he's like how how do we
know that's about that spot did that
right that hole in the ground
and because Miguel O'Hara tells his
story
you know
about who he is and like how he lost his
family due to that uh addiction and who
he is
so he found a universe where he is
murdered and dies
and he gets there at the moment of his
death so he can just replace himself
and now he has his family again that's
what he he wanted that was his intention
but what happened was that Universe
entirely fell apart rather than him
falling apart
because
he I guess messed up all these um what
do you call a Canon events in that
universe
and so I was like that's why we have to
keep this all together and we have to
enforce this to happen
right and then he
says you weren't supposed to be here and
you aren't
you're not supposed to be Spider-Man
right
because the spider Came From Another
Universe it was just supposed to bite
the Miles Morales of that universe
so when you see the because I've seen it
three times
there's actually you know spoiler alert
at the end Miles Morales has his other
half has a braids right yeah you could
see him in class studying and the
spider's about to bite him and then it
gets snatched up but that spider his its
purpose was still to bite Miles Morales
yeah and then they ended up buying miles
morons of that universe but Miles
Morales
of his Universe getting bit meant that
the Spider-Man into this universe died
so you just messed up the entire
timeline there you mess up the entire
Cannon so you're not even supposed to be
Spider-Man at all
and they just kind of shut them down
they say you don't belong here you're
not supposed to be here yeah which I
which was so good because when he said
that it kind of I didn't understand like
okay why the [__] would they want her
but not him right it's because he's not
supposed to be existent yes he [__] up
a timeline in general like he's the
Catalyst for the reason why all this
shit's happening I think they call it a
Nexus event in the Marvel yeah stories
or something but yeah so he's the reason
why all this [__] is happening and so I
never understood why it's like why the
[__] would they choose her over him and
like with the whole Canon event thing
like when that happened
I I thought Canon events were very
singular right but they're multiple
things that happen right within the
character of Spider-Man and so I I
couldn't wrap my head around why this
kid is such a [__] idiot
you know yeah I was getting pissed the
first time I saw it I was getting so
[__] frustrated right because the
Uncle Ben dying is one of the most major
parts for anybody who's not a Spider-Man
fan
is the biggest platform that caused this
change of character if you watch the
Spider-Man with uh Tom Holland yeah
right Tom Holland's character is also
this clumsy dumb teenage idiot yeah
until his candid event which was Aunt
May die yeah in that Universe right it
causes him to gain perspective it's that
whole Uncle Ben moment right where he
puts on this wisdom of
what was this What's the phrase again
um with great power comes great
responsible responsibility right and it
essentially changes his perspective of
who he is as a person I can't have my
cake into it too I have a responsibility
that I have to uphold and there are
things that are more important than what
my personal wants are right because I
took on this responsibility so my
personal wants aren't important now
right it's saving this world being a
superhero and I was like you went
through your candidate why the [__]
don't you understand this it's still me
yeah me me what about me what about me
and it was pissing me off but I think it
was because they told him
right and now it becomes kind of like
Minority Report
Tom Cruise
um because they told miles like your
dad's gonna die
you know that kind of and it has to
happen or else your entire universe will
be destroyed
and that's the thing about having his
caking eating it too he's like why can't
I do both why can't I save both
they're like you can't I just told you
you just can't yeah destroy the universe
he's like I'll figure out a way and this
is where you're like him and Tom Holland
too with
um the uh no way home when he was like
arguing with Dr Strange I was like this
little sagaji kid yeah easy shut the
[__] up right yeah but that's just my
age showing and he's saying this story
but then understanding that's just
happens to teenagers I'm sure so many of
my friends who have teenage you know
kids it's like they lie to you they
[__] deceive you they struck up
really bad that's the thing too like I
mean critical of this teenager being a
teenager right I like I'm not sure if
this is true right but I was thinking
about it when I was you know at home
just kind of mulling over it you know
like why why is he like this
right yeah like he had his cat and then
I thought too I was like maybe
his uncle dying isn't his candidate that
causes the moral change in him right and
the reason why I thought about that is
this
his dad being the captain and his father
at the same time is actually those two
events in one because
uncle Aaron was in his guidance exactly
yes uncle Aaron was a villain yeah you
know what I'm saying he actually doesn't
have a moral ground to give him guys or
say the things that he did Uncle Ben was
somebody that was his moral guidance
that he shunned yeah right that he
thought that what he was saying was
stupid right he ignored him that's his
father yeah yeah so his Canon event
actually it wasn't uncle Aaron it's his
dad dying yes and that's why he keeps
saying stupid [__] right because he
hasn't had his Uncle Ben and that's what
was [__] me up I was like his Uncle
Ben died his Uncle Ben died it's like no
it actually didn't it's his dad yeah
he's the one that he's emotionally
ignored he's the one that's imparting
wisdom upon that he thinks is dumb but
until his father dies and he starts to
realize his more like mortality is when
he starts having that moment in the film
where he goes like
I love my family yeah I gotta save my
dad so he it's like maybe the fault is
that they told him and then so I mean if
you were told hey your dad's gonna die
and you have to power the strength the
ability
to save him yeah right wouldn't you
right and that's the problem with Man of
Steel this [__] watches his dad
get sucked up in a hurricane
Chuck [__] [__] yeah I don't know
like that's the thing so
that is the metaphor that I saw with
what Miguel O'Hara and all the spider
people are trying to tell them right and
this is what the spider geeks on Twitter
and those right wing you know film
critics and like you know conservative
superhero you know mouthpieces on
YouTube are saying they won't call Miles
Morales Spider-Man they just call him
Miles Morales it's like a thing that
they do yeah right
and
that is expressed by all these other
Spider-Man like hey you're not a
Spider-Man yeah right
they're they're giving a mouthpiece to
that voice on the Internet by telling
them you're not even supposed to be
Spider-Man yeah right
and so
like they're expressing like this is
what a Spider-Man is right and even his
guidance canceled once again that blank
piece of paper like this what are you in
here right and everyone else is telling
miles as a Spider-Man this is what a
Spider-Man is so you gotta go through
this your dad has to die this is what
every Spider-Man fan is actually telling
miles hey
like if he if Mal makes Morales could
jump out of the pace this is why this is
a meta modern film like it's talking to
us if Miles Morales could jump out of a
page
and we're all telling him too hey
according to your story a Spider-Man you
have to go through this you have to go
through this that's what we're all
saying that's Canon we're all saying
that
but what is the film saying that's the
establishment right and Miles Morales is
trying to
you know like break that establishment
because who did it first Miguel O'Hara
he said he broke the establishment right
just like what I was saying the Gen X
postmodern guys they [__] around with
the format right but what happened to
one of them
as Zack Snyder he [__] with the Canon
he made Superman's dad get sucked up in
a hurricane yeah yeah yeah you [__]
with the cannon like
then we're gonna take your [__] then bad
things happen to you bad things happen
to you Zack Snyder because he [__]
with the DC Cannon yeah and the fans
chewed his ass out and they took that
[__] away from it that's like that
expresses like all of our frustrations
where we're watching this [__] film
yeah but when I started watching it too
and towards the end right we're gonna
talk about the end obviously as well
because right now he's like defying what
he has to go through the weird thing was
like it because it bothered me so much
I'm trying to find like trying to
rationalize his behavior but then when
they were talking about it it went back
to that moment where he goes you don't
belong here I was like well if he
doesn't belong here why does he have to
follow these rules and why is that a
catalyst for the world ending he doesn't
belong he's an anomaly maybe he could do
what he wants and create his Destiny
because you're right he's not supposed
to be Spider-Man right so maybe in this
reality which is a reality that's not
supposed to exist he's Spider-Man anyway
yeah why not have his own [__] story
exactly that's his argument that's why
he says let I mean then I'm gonna do my
own thing
I'm gonna do both I'm Gonna Save my dad
if I'm not as if I'm not like you then
[__] it everything everywhere all I want
same thing nothing if it doesn't matter
then [__] it I love you right if it
doesn't matter then [__] it I'm Gonna
Save my dad
like then if we say you're not supposed
to be but you still got to do this
establish it
what is that contradiction yeah yeah
yeah what the hell is that confusing
[__] right it's like no then give me the
space to do my own thing that I'm gonna
do my own thing but what happens when
they wanna they all fight they chasing
they want to take him down truth and
nail craziest [__] sequence ever too
by the way [__] amazing all the
different Spider-Man are different
animation Styles different looks
different pieces like different eras
like so [__] great the [__] spider
cat the T-Rex spider like everything it
was so amazing we can go on and on about
that but you know saying it in words
kind of hard to describe what we've
witnessed right
you know that long story short for this
basically you know you say he says his
line like I'm gonna do my own thing
right and he ends up going back into the
base to figure out how to get back to
his world so there is this spider
machine right that basically sends
people back to the to the place that
they're supposed to be yeah right so
Miguel is trying to uh Miguel uh
yeah Miguel no not Miguel [__] um
miles miles yeah miles is trying to
figure out this whole machine
right he finally gets it going
he is tossed into the machine turns out
it's a-okay he goes back into his world
and he's back to where he's supposed to
be he's in his room but what do we learn
as an audience from watching this film
how every Universe has its own
characteristics in its own aesthetic
once he get in there
it looks a little different yeah a bit
more darker blacks and but and like more
contrast more purples more Shadows kind
of thing we as an audience
no something is wrong yeah but we're
following the story and they're [__]
gaslighting us exactly right I want to
point out another thing another
important character is Peter B Parker
the sad depressed sport
um man uh Spider-Man of the first film
how miles inspired this guy to get his
[__] together right by being the good
leader that Miles needed like he needed
a Peter Parker to guide him right I
thought he ended up with this schlub
yeah yeah but they ended up needing each
other and helping each other out and he
was expressing to Miles look man I have
a kid because of you because you
inspired me to understand I could do
something like this
right
and this is the important thing like
we saw very poignant leadership within
that spider verse between three people
there was a Miguel O'Hara there was
Spider Woman and then there was Peter B
Parker right
yet still these youngins Gwen and Miles
reject all of them
they're still they want to do their own
thing
I think it's a poignant like story like
trying to express how this next
Generation gen Z they don't want to do
what we did you know they don't want to
do what you did either they need to
figure out they need a new method
they're going to figure it out this is
what I mean by a generational film that
just really expresses what the
what they're going to do what the future
is going to be like like
and what what they believe in right
because you look at Miles and the way he
is right
he is nurtured by very great parents
right
his mom in in the speech too like and
the way miles is his Nativity you might
say
somebody like Kevin Garnett
who had a grain and work hard and grew
up in the situation he lived in finally
gets his championship and then he
believes
anything is possible because he [__]
worked and went to the top and it's like
anything is possible
what's the complaint about gen Z they
already believe anything is possible
they didn't have to win the championship
they got all those participation
trophies that let him say see you can do
anything
right but we're salty about that the
older generation looks at that like you
[__] you weak ass participation trophy
[__] without realizing what does
that actually do for these kids who
believe them themselves yeah yeah yeah
that they can go outside of the box of
what we say they're supposed to do and
how they're supposed to do it yeah right
that's what I mean this is what I
learned
you know about young people they're
watching this film you know I watched
quantumania and I think kids are
[__] you know yeah I watched the
film this film and I'm like There's Hope
gen Z we gotta believe in them it's it's
a very hopeful film yeah right and that
ability especially like in the story
writing to kind of differentiate between
different generations and just like even
like parenting Styles right how none of
it's [__] working yeah it's
it's very reminiscent of now right
sometimes like even for me like when I
tried you know to to understand like a
younger generation right and not in a
hateful way but like I'll ask questions
it's hard for me to grasp it right
because I don't understand what they're
going through I don't see
what they've like even like on social
media right there's something missing
now now that I've reached this age like
I'm in my mid-30s between me and a 15
year old kid right that 20-year Gap is
vast so huge it's cavernous like I don't
know what the [__] is going on I don't
understand why a kid has to constantly
put his emotions out for the public to
see like sometimes I feel like I'm crazy
because I'm like what the [__] is that
like what what is that
is it because I was taught different is
it because what I think is better or
maybe what they're doing is right I
don't know because they're told that
expressing their emotions is healthy and
we were told we are gay yeah
that's what happened yeah we're called
the f word you're sad yeah you f word
like I feel like [__] you know and when
you see this too right like the film is
reminiscented that as well these kids
Gwen and miles
are here and these other Generations are
here and they just need to meet
somewhere in the [__] middle
[Music]
and this film is setting it up so well
we get back to our story and
Gwen
oh in the in the midst of all that chaos
spider punk as the anarchist he is
anti-establishment is his core
teachers miles you know about the Palm
technique like use your whole Palm right
and he loves starting the pot you know
he loves talking [__] and we also see
him he's been stealing [__] bits and
pieces from Miguel O'Hara's Tech
and we see why it's because he takes off
his thing he says he quits this [__]
he's not gonna chase miles but what he
really did was build his own little
wristband and so now his portal looks
like [__] magazine come out it's like
ah this Aesthetics of this film is you
could watch it all the goddamn a long on
Mew too like and just see this beautiful
picture
so
um miles ends up you know he's running
forgot to talk about something okay we
forgot to talk about Gwen and her dad
all right because because Gwen is
chasing
um wants was standing up for miles and
mcgillah kicks her out and sends her
back home gets rid of her [__] uh her
watch or her wristband that kind of
keeps her within different dimensions
universes yeah different universes this
was this scene and I can't believe I
forgot to mention this part was [__]
amazing to me yeah when I was watching
it and this is where I where I was
talking about how they did it so well in
the first team between her father and
her and how different they are right
yeah and how they do it with the scenery
they portray emotion and what's
happening through the scenery yeah as
well as the dialogue and let's not
forget when he has his gun pointed at
her and she reveals her face
the lighting on him gets split in half
one half is red and one half is blue
right and she's trying to convince him
and he can see his head [__] spinning
and he's red and blue and then when he
like [__] turns all blue he says you
have the right to remain silent right
and so they express like what their
thoughts and feelings are so I looked
into it and then
I guess the art directors or the
director of the animation they were
saying Gwen's universe is a giant mood
ring
so whatever anyone's feeling is the
color that's going on every single
character so that's why in those scenes
it's like that yeah that makes sense
yeah and that's that's what I first
picked up I'm like you don't have to
guess [__] this you know what I'm saying
and it just only amplifies what's being
said and done in the scene yeah which I
really really appreciated right like
everything out there you could see you
could see the room it's there right but
it's really just background to express
how the person feels
when they confront each other
and they start having their conversation
and she starts pouring her heart out
background melts
right and even around her father [__]
melts and the color Fades and now the
colors only expressed through them too
as everything's going away
and when he expresses how he quit being
a captain the moment because he found
out his daughter is Spider Woman right
this is abstract art like the background
is just something else has nothing to do
with where they are it's like they're in
their own Universe where they have their
[__] moment together in that
reconciliation as if the whole world
doesn't [__] matter right which is
expressing beef too which we'll get to
someday promise guys yeah but
and then as soon as they they go in for
the hug like boom that it goes away
they're back into reality like in their
connection and then Gwen gets that
realization if you if
he quits being a captain he's not gonna
die he's not gonna die
and so she gets his Revelation like oh
[__] then
I can
I can help miles I can save help save
his father
and then
what happens what's his face uh Spider
Punk comes through because he had built
his own wrist watch thing traveling
watch because he stole all of those
parts
and then so you know in the beginning of
the film she quits her band because it
is not something that she whether she
doesn't feel like she belongs like
that's that's not the release she was
getting out of it but then what she is
doing is
getting a band together of just these
spider people who stand with her like
hey yeah like
like people who stand up with miles of
spider people who should have their own
story who still believe in doing the
right thing because before Gwen gets
shipped off and kicked out she says I
thought we were the good people I
thought we were the good guys right and
he's like we are the good guys turns
around like we are the good guys
it's like a bit antagonistic yeah yeah
yeah
and so music is building up
miles
um Gwen is chasing and trying to get to
Miles apartment
Miguel O'Hara and his crew of people he
trusts now which is not Peter B Parker
Spider-Man and the Scarlet Spider which
is voiced by a Lonely Island dude with
the nose oh uh Andy Samberg yeah yeah
yeah that's why he sounds like a surfer
douche okay but
um his animation style is dubbed too um
super 90s
but they post up and they're
um waiting for miles to get home and
we're seeing miles running home too
but uh we see
Gwen Stacy take down Scarlet Spider you
know when he's a mental on his
monologues
and then she posts up to Miles bedroom
when miles is there
and his mom catches him in his room and
he finally gets a way to express to his
mom you know and finally tell her
because he's saying like I did exactly
what she told me they told me I didn't
belong but I fought him and I beat them
all I'm strong now I know I power him up
like you know and so now he has a
confidence to tell her boom I'm
Spider-Man she has no idea who the [__]
is that who is that right he's like what
you know like Spider-Man she was like I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about
and then
when they go on to the living room boom
the door opens and it's unclear and it's
like wait a second's dead right no and
then he's starting to realize because he
buzzes out for a second
like oh [__]
he's in the wrong universe and it says
boom Earth 42.
and then both uh uncle Aaron and his
mom's like what'd you do to your hair
he's like just take your braids out or
whatever
and so he's just trying to play along
like oh [__] I'm in the wrong universe
and we're seeing him give him his mom
like a stack of cash like Hey we're
family here take care of you guys so you
know Uncle Aaron's
hustling doing his thing he's like hey
we gotta go do some taking up to the
roof and he's texting somebody the
camera shifts and you see that just this
very dark intention in unclear's face
and boom mouse gets knocked out
and then in that moment we're also
seeing Gwen walks into his bedroom and
she's in the wrong Universe everybody
realizes they're amazing Universe
they're all in the wrong Universe does
that spider that bit him in that
universe is not his universe and that
machine only knows it put people to
where they're supposed to be and if he's
the Spider-Man he's supposed to be in 42
yes and so he's in the wrong place or
the right place but he gets knocked out
when he wakes up he's back at Uncle
Aaron's apartment and who comes out to
confront him is the prowler of this
universe but this Prowler has got Jordan
Ones in purple
takes off his mask it's [__] miles
and also
miles sees the mural that was Uncle
Aaron is actually his father because in
this universe his father was killed
I thought this was an interesting
commentary
I felt like it was saying
if Miles Morales loses his father
that and he is then under the influence
of his uncle then he will become a
gangster
like a bad guy an antagonist
which was I'm not sure what they're
going with it but that's exactly what
happened yeah when I when I thought
about that I thought um
it was actually something that's very
hopeful and the reason why I say hopeful
is because the idea behind the Canon
events for Spider-Man is that it's for
his own good yeah right but the Canon
events in this world because he's a he's
an anomaly his father dying is actually
something bad yes so maybe these
Spider-Mans are are [__] wrong you're
wrong like he gets to create his own
destiny so when I saw that his father
died and then he turned out bad I'm like
oh this is what he was talking has to
save his father yeah yeah so it's
different for him like he can create his
own destiny he needs that Father Figure
there because if not his father figures
uncle Aaron and uncle Aaron is not a
good person right right but the
and the way the story is told though
that Prowler who is Miles he became
Prowler because he was supposed to
become Spider-Man that spider's
total intention was to bite Miles
Morales of Earth 42 but because it
bought bit Miles Morales of a universe
where he wasn't Spider-Man
ending up with the Peter Parker of that
of his Universe dying
it's the that's where I am like very a
lot of processing and the questions come
because you're like okay then
if that Miles Earth 42 wasn't didn't
have the Spider-Man powers
then it does is that what makes him an
antagonist because if Miles Morales with
the Spider-Man Powers father dies
you know
then will it make him antagonistic is
there a possibility that the Miles
Morales we know and that were that we
love will become antagonistic if this
but maybe that Spider-Man's evil oh [__]
I think that happens that's what's going
to happen yeah you know who needs a
Venom Suit yeah yeah
but still Gwen Stacy has
her proof like hey maybe it doesn't
happen that way you know in our
universes maybe we can make our own
story but with all the questions that we
have
to be continued yeah
some one of the best Cliffhangers I've
ever been left on dude that [__] it was
like damn this is so good but I was like
God damn I want to know so bad yeah and
they got my ass they [__] got my ass
man but then I looked back and I was
like wait like two and a half hours past
yeah this movie can't go any longer I
was feeling that too I was like because
it was kind of spoiled for me because on
Twitter uh super viral post was
Spider-Man beyond the spider verse March
2024. in 10 months yeah so I was like oh
so I'm guessing that it's gonna be I I
thought in my head they made this movie
back to back just like they did Infinity
war end game yeah to release it a year
later but apparently what actually
happened was if you remember
into the spider-verse came out in 2018
that's [__] five years ago
this apparently this movie was supposed
to come out last year oh [__] but they
held it back a whole year because of the
pandemic oh my God yeah so
marketing wise it worked out for them
yeah it would have been terrible yeah it
would have been [__] terrible yeah
but this is like
like if you haven't watched this you
should right if you are a comic book fan
right and we've we've seen some pretty
bad Renditions of
comic book takes going into film right
but the great thing about comic books
going into film that's still a comic is
that your wildest imagination that you
saw on a piece of paper really comes to
life in this film in the best way
[__] possible and I almost thought to
myself after was do I even want
live-action versions anymore yeah like
do I because of Animation the the
possibilities are endless Avatar 2 prove
that you can do any [__] thing create
an entire [__] Universe yeah
but like I think another important part
was
um spot
because that guy is the big picture
antagonist of the next movie as well
and I try to kind of look at it because
there's like I said this movie is super
meta commentary it's speaking to us at
us right
so then I was like but then what the
[__] is spot right
and then you look at him aesthetically
as a design he's just a white paper
sketch
right
and I kept thinking about the lady with
the empty blank paper like
remember how in those classic Looney
Tune cartoons sometimes they'll break
the fourth wall and a giant pencil will
come in oh yeah yeah or erase [__] right
and I looked at
the character spot himself and why he
becomes a greater villain than what he
is than what he started off in the movie
and says this [__] goofball and at
the end he's actually intimidating and
scary and threatening and how he became
that right
it's like and why he keeps saying you
and I are inexplicably linked you
created me and I created you kind of
thing
so then like what is spot
like a blank piece of paper right the
sketch just the the bones and the
skeleton of something that could be
potentially greater on a blank piece of
canvas
right
but miles
and I think that might be a commentary
on the the
let's say the more negative aspects of
gen Z is someone who doesn't respect him
calls him the villain of the week
right even though he's just a blank
piece he's just starting out doesn't see
his potential right while believing in
himself as like something great and
awesome like a little bit of hypocrisy
there yeah right
that's how I kind of started seeing spot
and like by the third time I saw it
right because like I said everything
else is an analogy in a meta commentary
and so much other things but then I'm
starting to see a big picture
like way of
like seeing somebody like spot and
if you [__]
you know [__] on something in its
conception and you just throw it out you
take away essentially what it could be
and then you see his design being like
I don't know how to say this but then
I've seen some like psychological art
like from schizophrenic people
it's like
Disturbed mind art yeah
like towards the end of the film right
um
like spot kind of loses his Spotlight
right so you kind of get into the
storyline of
everyone else split spot right and which
is kind of funny because that's
essentially why he becomes a [__]
villain so to see that happen again was
kind of making me laugh a little bit
when I was like thinking about it at
night and then I think it's smart as
[__] yeah yeah it fed into their story
yeah and it was so funny too like
looking at somebody like spotted who
also reminds me of you know the kids
like oh you're you're an afterthought
like blah blah blah but he keeps on
saying like no I created you yeah and it
kind of reminds me of just how sometimes
a younger generation they forget like a
lot of their stuff and their creativity
came because of a generation before you
right right like the dudes that they've
paid and they paved the way and now that
you're doing your cool stuff that they
set up for you you just kind of go you
don't know [__] anything it's like
but that's the argument of the other
Spider-Man right exactly what you're
saying that that's the commentary of
what's in our real world yeah and then
they adapted that into Miguel O'Hara
saying exactly what you're saying except
I mean you're you're pointing it out but
for him it's like real yeah in the
characters yeah so like I think like
when you read the lines like that like
you you'll start seeing the meta
commentary and other things like okay
Batman v Superman right
everyone was pissed that Batman was
straight up murdering these people in
fact you could say that Zack Snyder was
[__] with the Canon by having Batman
cause vehicular homicide you know and
just straight up murder people
but
when you saw that backlash from the fans
and the internet and everyone's like
Batman doesn't kill Batman doesn't kill
and whatever right
and then you watch the movie
that's the entire Point that's why
Superman had beef with him he was like
why are you killing people yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's actually a story like
hey stop killing and he was like what
are you talking about you killed all
those people in the city
but I think because of the established
Minds that we have of who Batman and
Superman are
that story couldn't be properly
expressed because people already had
their mind set up of who they are yeah
right and so that's
you know I'm sure because it's a Marvel
property they weren't trying to make any
kind of DC analogy of what actually
happened in that whole Saga but that's
exactly what they're talking about but
the fans reaction with Canon because we
all look at Spider-Man
and the reason why we love Spider-Man is
because we do kind of see ourselves
behind the mask and through all these
new reiterations of Spider-Man being
like there's even a Korean Spider-Man
Spider Woman right silkworm oh yeah yeah
Cindy Moon she's a Spiderman or
Spider-Woman right Korean American dope
right because it all stemmed from the
idea that we could all be Spider-Man
you know and they're telling that meta
commentary yet they're pointing out the
toxicity of us saying that's not
Spider-Man Spider-Man doesn't do that
and
Miles Morales the character himself he's
being like what if I didn't listen to
any of you [__]
the Spider-Man in my life
or even the you guys who are watching
and we don't know what's gonna happen
next
even Mary Jane
um
uh Peter B Parker goes back to his
Universe they tuck their baby in and
Mary Jane gives a sports analogy say
you're gonna have to regroup and
re-strategize at halftime
little did many of us know that it was
just gonna end yeah and call it halftime
and that's the kind of cliffhanger I
love it's like we have so many questions
and it's like it's there to wait and
they made us [__] starve and we're
all gonna be there next year a hundred
percent yeah
so like
this movie
not only do I think should get best
animated feature Oscar I think it should
be best picture nominated oh 100 man
it's up there for me if anything else
that's the one it should win like
for me to watch something and say I need
to re-watch it not only just for the
story that I fell in love with and to
watch all you know the meta messages
within the film yeah I just want to see
all the visual stuff I missed you need
to enjoy that again like you need to
sink it in again that's genius films man
the [__] that makes your ass go back to
the [__] theater and pay that price
it's like why people love [__] known
films right the re-watch ability you
gotta see it again uh Tarantino the
rewatch ability you gotta see it again
start noticing all these little things
that are different because once you've
kind of taken the whole picture now you
could hyper focus on something else and
and this is where I want to [__]
praise Chris uh Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller
these guys I first I didn't know them
are here of them until Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs right and I [__]
love that movie and it's a Kids film
right and then so I did my I do my geeky
nerd [__] IMDb and whatever and realize
they made one of my favorite High School
TV shows Clone High
right what's that 100 Clone High is
about
this mad scientist who clones historical
figures and they grow up and he's
watching over them so he's the principal
right it's all these historical figures
are in high school and they're all
interacting in like like interacting
with each other so it's like uh JFK is
the popular kid and Abraham Lincoln is
the nerdy like loner kid but uh Joan of
Arc is the uh the the girl that he's in
love with the Gandhi is the like with
ADHD like sidekick friend and so there's
all these people in it and I Remember
Loving that show and I was like oh maybe
that's why I love Cloudy With The Chance
of Meatballs then I'm always on the
radar for these guys right then they
make
um 21 and 22 Jump Street so they go from
a Kids film to rated R and they knock it
out the [__] part yeah and what else
it's also a meta commentary about us in
our generation as Millennials right
and
then they do the [__] Lego Movie
so good so good then they produce the
sequels and they they produce the Lego
Batman movie which those Lego movies are
also like Multiverse movies these guys
[__] get that [__]
you know then um
I think they produce Mitchell's versus
machines
like
um last man on Earth was was the
funniest show on Fox back in the day not
back in the day a few years ago but um
then they got
hired by Disney to direct the Han Solo
movie
they spent millions of dollars on that
[__] it was a budget of 100 Mil
and they were running out of money I
think they spent already 75 million and
they were like 75 80 percent done
filming and they [__] fired them
for real they fired them you know
because the the writer of solo was the
guy who [__] helped write Empire
Strikes Back
you know and the Return of the Jedi
these OG Star Wars dude right and Disney
Star Wars hired the OG guy to tell us
the OG story of of Han Solo but they
hired these young up and coming fresh
Minds to direct it to bring it to this
next Generation to you know get to know
Han Solo
they didn't like their work in their
dailies they didn't understand their
work process they didn't understand
because if you see 2122 Jump Street it
is a lot of improv right yeah that
pissed off that writer
pissed them off real bad because he's
like [__] OG Star Wars guys that
you're [__] with my script
so Disney fired them and they hired Ron
Howard to continue to finish the movie
but you know what they did they [__]
re-shot everything oh God damn and they
made the guy that they hired as Han Solo
take acting classes because they didn't
like the job he was doing
you know damn yeah they [__] just
took it over so
these guys who wrote this film
[__] sounds like they [__] with a
Canon event yeah they took that [__]
away from them they destroyed it all
this is what I mean about Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller they've experienced
exactly what they're talking about in
Spider-Man with Star Wars
they're allowed to portray really well
yeah they they had they got [__]
fired
but guess what happened they also wrote
and produced into the spider-verse right
Han Solo came out and bombed right
everyone was just like [__] whack
nobody liked it they didn't know who the
movie was for they didn't understand the
direction of the film
in that very same year
they [__] win the Academy Award
for best anime to feature for into the
spider-verse and Phil Lord goes up there
with the [__] Academy
and because Hollywood knows his story
they got [__] fired from Star Wars
roaring Applause because look at this
guy he got fired last year and he won an
Oscar right like that's why I [__]
love those guys they make great [__]
films and they killed it with this one
again and can I just say something right
and this is like we grew up you know
obviously we're kind of young for it but
we still grew up when the you know the
era of Star Wars fandom you know
sometimes crusty people need to
understand you're crusty right but you
had uh George Lucas come back and he
wanted to it which which one was it it
was episode one was it yeah Phantom
Menace
episode three it was the one where
basically Darth Vader was screaming oh
yeah yeah episode three yeah and that's
that's when George Lucas wanted to come
in and he goes I want to do this right
and it was just like what the [__] is
this right it was so corny yeah the
thing that I think a lot of like Star
Wars fans don't realize right
um and this is for me of somebody who is
a Star Wars fan the reason why Star Wars
did really well back in the day wasn't
because the script and the acting was
amazing it was because the tech was
[__] nuts yes it was their Avatar
yeah you know what I'm saying it was
like dude what the [__] are we watching
this is insane I I talked to to my buddy
Kenneth Ken's older than me right he's
like 10 or 15 years older he says he
remembers when Star Wars came out right
it was the day that I was
I was like one or two one years old or
something like that or maybe it was okay
now the last Star Wars came out in 1983.
the first one was 1987 what no the first
one was like 78 78 there you go yeah
right that was about to say 87 like
somewhere around there
he says he remembers waiting in line
for like five six hours to watch it and
then the next day or the next viewing he
waited back in line again
to watch it again that's how
mind-blowing Star Wars was and what they
were watching it wasn't because the
[__] great dialogue it wasn't because
of any of that [__] yeah it was just
because technologically it was [__]
never in space yeah in 1978. and so you
know you had these writers who come in
and they go no I know the writing nobody
[__] liked it because of the writing
to be honest with you yeah not because
the dialogue or anything else like that
I'm sorry to say like it just they're
trying to adapt that and put it into now
it doesn't work do you know the the
behind the scenes stories about why the
prequels are so [__] bad no so
um
when George Lucas was making Star Wars
he had a lot of Studio interference
because he was like this is his second
movie ever you know and it was this huge
[__] Space Opera piece you know
and
um not only that like he was married to
a woman who was a script doctor
she worked on his script to make it
workable and all the people on set
acting this out everybody was saying
this is [__] stupid
but they were just following and doing
it right but you know what it comes out
as a [__] hit right and there now
they got to make a sequel right Studio
said to George Lucas you can't direct it
there's a lot a lot of people like
forget or don't know because they don't
go on IMDb like I do
George Lucas didn't Direct
you know Empire Strikes Back or Return
of the Jedi he wrote it he produced it
but then Fox got like seasoned directors
who knew what they were doing to direct
these films you know and they got you
know and he like I said he had a script
doctor wife to help him fix the script
and make sure it worked it makes sense
it made sense yeah and then everything
else you know was all the effects and
all that
we'll fast forward 20 years
Star Wars is just this huge thing right
um it's now
1996 or something and fox is like please
George Lucas will you will you like make
some more Star Wars movies like look at
how many years since it's been since any
new Star Wars content it's still [__]
huge in American you know pop culture is
never gonna die
and that's the thing
the a studio executive in 1978 to the
studio executive in 1996 is two
different people two different mindsets
two other things that guy in 96 revered
George Lucas because in Hollywood
that's what happens one person gets all
the credit despite all the other people
who come in to help fix the film
and these new studio execs looked at
George Lucas like he was the God because
he created Star Wars and gave him full
hundred percent control of Star Wars
and that's why the prequels are the way
they are because that makes so much 100
instead of getting help with somebody to
doctor his script make it work make it
not is it true that like on was it
episode three which was the last one
that came out right like that was like
George Lucas just Hands-On on everything
yeah it was terrible yeah it was so bad
and when you say that that's his
original script without the script
doctoring without script doctoring yeah
like when [__] no I everybody
I never knew that you could hear
people's eye roll like it was like yeah
what the [__] was this everybody was
pissed in that theater but you know Star
Wars prequel memes is huge they have two
million Subs on Reddit it's just prequel
memes
the rule is Star Wars only in the
prequels and they take all of these
stupid ass [__] lines and make memes
out of it and it's endless content
because he's corny as [__]
right and so like that's the the kind of
model we've lived in like and that's
what
Phil Lord and Christopher Miller is the
story kind of story they're telling in
this meta response like they've been
victims of the Canon and the fandom and
everybody telling them what Star Wars is
and they got [__] fired for it you
know I do before we end this podcast too
I I do want to address this right and
it's from a few comments of people who
listen to our last review for The Last
of Us yeah and some new people too who
are hardcore gaming fans and I do want
to tell you this is like they're like
well you you would appreciate it more if
you you wouldn't like the TV show as
much if you watched the game if you
played the game and I think that's
literally the dumbest thing that you
could ever [__] say ditto that's
[__] dumb
a TV series film piece whatever that it
is is a standalone project in and of
itself right they're like it should be
exactly like the game no it shouldn't
yeah because you cannot adapt your per
because they're mixing their personal
emotion that they felt in the room
playing the game with that anxiety and
say like I didn't feel like what I felt
when I played the game yeah no [__] you
weren't controlling the character yeah
right and they they're like well this is
Joel was a badass all the way through
till the end it's like that is great for
you in your little [__] world when
you're sitting and playing that game but
in a person from somebody like me who
doesn't know about the game and I see
that I hate the show I was like who the
[__] is this guy why is he just a badass
throughout the whole why is he doing
this yeah you don't want any of that
that doesn't make any [__] sense like
it doesn't and by the way the source
material is there with the people
creating it and they enjoy the
improvements on the film or the TV show
better yeah so what the [__] are you
talking about it is like they're saying
that they're protecting their virginity
card yeah it's like hey thanks for
letting us yeah
nerd like geek you are like you're the
kind of nerd that makes being a nerd
uncool you know it wasn't exactly how I
felt when I played the game if you play
the game you would know how you're
supposed to feel when you watch it I'm
like David you don't feel the way I feel
it's like oh my gosh shut the [__] up
yeah I'm like what the [__] up please
like it doesn't make sense for how
enjoyable the TV series was right
because the emotion that you felt
playing the game didn't match up to what
other people were watching while they
were watching the show how the [__] does
that make sense yeah like that doesn't
and what I mean by that is that it's not
a fair critique and it doesn't
how is it a critique at all I just don't
understand maybe I'm missing something
here because I have seen things that
I've been a fan of and I see adaptation
towards film and they've changed things
and it was perfectly fine yeah because
it made more sense it's just because
it's different some people can't handle
different I know I can't many times when
things change up sometimes I feel some
type of way with when things changing up
but then I have to [__] get my [__]
together and like understand that it
might not that be that big of a deal and
I accept what the [__] is in front of me
for what it is
very childish honestly it's a very baby
way of talking honestly and this one you
know it does and I bring this up because
of rap backs it wraps back to the idea
of
these cat these uh the Canon Parts yeah
you it has to be this right it has to be
it has to be that if not it sucks it has
to be this and it kind of goes back to
that and they're really tackling it
really well yeah well
like I said the end of this film left us
with a lot of questions right which we
can't wait to see
you know in the next one
and
with the way I was seeing it like I I
told you everything about the Matrix
right
and you know and I was comparing it also
to everything everywhere all at once and
with everything everywhere all at once
it's also like the precursor to that
movie I keep thinking is the first
Matrix
so if I look at into the spider-verse as
Matrix one right
where they establish
who the one is and what he is and how
awesome he is and that's somebody we
know that's the hero's journey right
which is into the spider-verse one it's
his miles hero's journey they they take
the classic formula of like Luke
Skywalker and like all these people the
heroes Journey
they [__] take the metalness like
into the next level of that
like it's still at its core
like the hero's journey now the Matrix
two
said hey remember that hero's journey
boom flip it on his head right and [__]
with you
and say like there's people in control
of that story right and they use that
story to control you
right and then now I'm looking at this
Spider-Man across the the spider-verse
and it is talking about the
establishment
control of the story and remember in
Matrix two Neil's fight was for his own
choice to make his own decision yeah
right and here we go with Miles with
that fight in control to make his own
decisions
not saying the next Spider-Man is going
to be like Matrix three right I hope not
but the core of Matrix three is also
saying the resolution right
like how they get all this [__] together
like every single piece of everybody's
story and how they come to a resolution
that works for everyone is what I'm so
excited for and I have high hopes and
expectation from Lord and Miller to
write that story it's actually pretty
insane how different
um into the spider-verse is compared to
the second reiteration yes it's actually
substantially different which I didn't
expect it's like it's almost I'm now
almost scared to watch the first one I'm
gonna feel like that it's kind of slow
you know I'm gonna watch the first one
again I know I'm still gonna love the
[__] out of it
like okay then before we leave
is this the best Spider-Man movie the
date for me a hundred percent yeah I
mean it's a hundred percent yeah like it
doesn't even come close I thought I
liked the Tom Holland one that's like
here it's yeah it's not even
so now I'm like so I made a list too
and because there are 10 Spider-Man
movies now right
like
in my head automatically if this one
across the spider versus number one
number 10 is probably Spider-Man three
oh yeah that I mean that's for everybody
though yeah
be like number nine is Amazing
Spider-Man 2 yeah
and then number eight would be amazing
Spider-Man one
number seven is tough because like the
rest of them are pretty decent from year
on
but then I might say Spider-Man 1 with
uh
Tobey Maguire um
that means number six
would leave us with uh
I think I would say uh
far from home where he goes to Europe
because I felt like I mean just looking
at the movie again it just feels like
Disney's
European Cash Cash grab to be like hey
Spider-Man's not always in New York yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but um
and then I would say Spider-Man 2 Tobey
Maguire
and then I would say uh
homecoming
and then no way home
spider into the spider-verse and then
yeah yeah across by version number one
with that Gap from one to like three is
Big it's huge yeah it's pretty big like
I uh because because no way home was a
meta not metaverse Multiverse story
it wasn't
the way it wasn't expressed the way
across the spider verse speaks directly
to us right yeah yeah it's it hits a lot
different and well like I don't think we
can ever replace you know human actors
because obviously the way that we emote
and stuff it's yeah yeah I cried in that
when I watched and may die right it was
pretty [__] amazing yeah but I think
like the possibilities of what you can
do with animation when it comes to a
comic book is is unmatched yeah it's
gonna do it this way yeah yeah well guys
that wraps up this episode of The Genius
brain podcast I hope you enjoyed that
review we will get to that beef review
um there's just so much [__] that came
in it's just too heavy man it hurts to
watch so many episodes like that's gonna
be a breakdown yeah yeah so uh you can
catch genius brain every Sundays at 12
p.m and you can catch it at edparkvp and
Bible study at Momos uh we'll see y'all
next time peace